So for Space Force.
[Conan] Yes.
We did this game night thing.
And most of the cast of
Space Force was there.
And I was winning.
It was tied between me and Steve Carell.
And what we had to do
was go into our house
and find some novelty mug,
and then that would decide who won.
[Conan] Yeah?
So he went,
and first thing I could
think of Conan, was this.
Does this look familiar to you?
Yes!
Right?
I do remember that.
Yes.
Right?
And so I don't even.
I was so happy and I just said, this!
This is from Conan's
first year on Late Night
and there wasn't even,
it didn't even say Late
Night with Conan O'Brien.
And I still have it.
[Conan] Right.
And this is it.
But is that right?
Yeah.
I think so.
I think we, early on, they
weren't sure I was gonna make it,
so they didn't wanna put
my name on any of the mugs.
They just wanted if another host took over
they wanted to just be
able to use the same mugs.
(Lisa laughs)
So yes, you're right.
I think that's from the first season
when pre putting my name on anything.
And so did you win because of that?
Yes!
Because it was TV history.
Like they all viewed it as,
okay that is TV history.
That's monumental.
Yes.
But then I woke up in
the middle of the night
and I thought, wait, I
wasn't on Conan's show
his first year.
But I think you got a mug.
How?
I don't know, I think we were friends
and you visited and I think you took one.
[Lisa] I just took one.
Remember when you used to,
I don't know if you want this out or not,
but you used to steal
things, take things a lot.
Well.
Remember?
Let me rephrase that.
In the 90s, you stole things.
Oh better thanks.
After the first year my
name started to go on stuff.
Then starting about a
year ago they started
taking it off stuff again.
(both laugh)
It must be fun getting to work with,
I mean it's a great cast, Space Force
and you're working
with my old writing partner, Greg Daniels.
Yeah, how about that?
This must be, yeah.
We used to all hang out in
the day, back long time ago.
Greg Daniels was my writing partner
and this was back when I think you knew me
Greg and I shared--
Everything.
We shared a car.
(Lisa laughs)
So if one of us got a date,
we had to ask the other one
to borrow the car.
We shared an apartment.
We had desks that faced
each other at work.
And I think after a year and a half
we wanted to kill each other.
(laughs) We absolutely
wanted to kill each other.
It was sort of preparation for right now.
Yes, that was our preparation
for this time we're going through.
You were quarantined
after college together.
(both laugh)